if you're in HR you know that at times
the hiring process can be super
frustrating let's face it managing even
a single job posting takes up valuable
time and slows you down while a list of
these mundane tasks could go on forever
you're probably dealing with several
common challenges from manual management
and tracking to endless copying and
pasting across different platforms it's
easy to get sidetracked from working on
the important stuff but what if you had
more digital use to take on the routine
parts of the hiring process well say
hello to your very own Digi a digital
sidekick that's ready to take these on
with Watson orchestrate digi's handle
the monotony of the hiring process for
you alleviating the stress of your job
you can ask your Digi to do lots of
things let's start by asking your Digi
to create a job posting your Digi
confined copy and share the job
description template with the hiring
manager you'll automatically get
reminders for when it's updated and
approved and eliminate unnecessary back
and forth Digis will also alert you when
there's a need to create new ones Okay
so we've created the posting now let's
get it noticed creating a social media
post can be just as easy and to be
honest lots of fun for example your Digi
can quickly post and advertise the job
opening for you and you can even share
the job opening with the sample message
with the hiring team so they can help
you reach great candidates in their
networks too it's that easy
now that you're done creating the post
and socializing it we're on to the most
important part connecting with
candidates your Digi can work with lots
of different systems and pull a list of
potential candidates for your job
posting the candidate's contact
information is all in one place so you
can easily reach out and encourage them
to apply
watch how your Digi helps you identify
the candidates in the job postings
location and that's just the beginning
with Watson orchestrate and your Digi
you can do more than speed up the hiring
process you can focus on what matters
most your people
thanks for watching please follow the
links to get started with Watson
orchestrate for free